[Musique]
trois
mieux que de faire un lundi soir cette
organisation t'a vu pas mal
et nous t'aimons vraiment et je crois à
100% que tu vas aller au premier tour
non j'ai l'impression que partout où je  continue
me rappelle ce qui s'est passé ce qui s'est passé à
propos de cette merde et s'il ne résistait pas à l'
arrestation, il le serait toujours donc si je
résiste à l'arrestation tu vas me tirer dessus je
sais ce que tu penses avoir vu commencer des
problèmes maintenant vers le service à
tout le monde va '  le flic va trop loin et maintenant
nous sommes tous coupables alors vous dites que Larson est
juste la victime de ce mois-ci je veux
m'impliquer faites ce que vous faites alors qu'est-ce que la
police veut de vous
vous voulez que je me taise
j'ai vu la bande et alors quoi  tu vas en
parler ils vont faire
de toi un exemple que dois-je faire
ça va un nouveau boulot je suis sur le point d'être diplômé
tout va changer si tu
mets ça là-bas
que ferais-tu que ferais-tu  si
quelqu'un de deux fois votre taille vient vers
vous, il était entouré de six ou huit
s  secondes Lisa
[Musique] les
villes vont continuer à brûler les enfants
vont continuer à se faire tirer dessus
les flics vont continuer à descendre vous
le sortez jamais
[Applaudissements]
vous n'avez aucune idée que vous n'avez aucune idée de
ce qui se passe dans les rues vous voyez
trois  minutes d'une vidéo tremblante et vous
pensez que vous savez ce que vous faites